colombia superó las 70 mil muertes por
kobe 19 tras registrar un récord fúnebre
el jueves
430 personas perdieron la vida en el
país la cifra más alta desde el inicio
de la pandemia
colombia se encuentra inmersa en plena
tercera ola y las autoridades han
endurecido las restricciones en las
principales ciudades como bogotá cali y
medellín donde la ocupación de las
unidades de cuidados intensivos se
acerca al 90%
los toques de queda nocturnos se han
extendido a nivel nacional igual que las
cuarentenas totales durante los fines de
semana
la alcaldesa de bogotá auguró un futuro
difícil durante los próximos días es
posible que hoy cerremos a 90%
ocupaciones y hoy y sigue creciendo y
sigue que sobre todo en estas dos
semanas que vamos a pasar por un momento
de verdad muy muy muy crítico estamos
literalmente entre la vida y la muerte
de la mano desde el inicio de la semana
las muertes diarias por kobe 19 no han
bajado de las 400 el 20 de abril también
tuvo un récord de fallecidos mientras el
gobierno trata de avanzar en su plan de
vacunación se han inoculado más de 41
millones de dosis especialmente a
adultos mayores y otros grupos
prioritarios aunque menos de un millón y
medio de personas están inmunizadas con
las dos dosis en un país con más de 50
millones de habitantes